try to get into the office through the
doors and ventilation system if you see
him running to a door close it and don't
open it until he has gone far away or he
will come back if he gets in the vents
checking the duck tears
it's the one that connects to the
hallways check which door he will run to
and close it
if he's in one of the Ducks connecting
to the office turn off all the light
sources
and hide until you stop hearing his
footsteps that's a lot of complications
that's a lot of complications
hello welcome back to glitched
attraction I'm gonna die
many many times
if you see someone on the side of a
monitor it means they can see you or
something like that I bet it was creepy
whatever it was let me read through
these again these monitors check rooms
near you use leverage to turn all
systems off
he's lever next to the doors to open and
close them okay
avoid looking at them okay
free dumb complete the puzzles
so developer mode was part of it I just
didn't know how to get out of the
let's save the children game concerning
well I know how to kick this bad boy off
oh my God it's gone it's
four nine nine nine nine two three one
wait
wait four nine nine nine two three one
wait a minute
four nine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was it four nine nine nine two three one
oh
is that bad is that a bad thing
[Music]
oh where is that main room camera main
room what does that mean main room
well don't do that to me
whoa
what do I do
that doesn't sound good see I still
don't know what to do about him hey
huh
oh
[Music]
nope
Okay so
what do I do okay you're there
and oh there's and red oh
hmm well that's a problem
well you're still there
see
I don't know what to do about that
are you there
oh boy why did I lose that forever
I don't feel like that was oh my God oh
my God
I feel like that was very fair oh you're
back again
well this is this is bad
oh that oh oh wait wait wait turn off
all power I know this one turn off all
power oh [__]
[Music]
hey wait a minute oh
see I see I I feel like uh I feel like
uh maybe oh maybe I don't know which I
thought because it looked like it was in
the middle it'd be the one that connects
to the office but apparently that wasn't
it
nothing is hidden here look elsewhere
let's try that again
ah 213-7277
[Music]
balloons wait balloon boy needs balloons
right I see balloons there you have
balloons okay easy easy perfect
I figured that doing this right off the
bat might be the best
fire protocol
whoa
c4de is missing I don't know what that
means how oh God I can't get out of it
okay
okay well that's whoa that's bad wait
wait
shut up no yes bad
am I I'm dead
I I'm dead
well you gotta squish my brain
why you gotta be squishing my brain like
that because my brain is
too big to be squished doors won't stop
dread bear even if you close them after
he sees you
but
what do you mean what do you mean you
didn't give me any information on dread
bear
what does JED bear mean
what do you mean by dread bear why do I
keep crouching
okay
last night what did I just do I crouched
okay I'm just gonna stay there generator
status
well
now I don't even know where it is
I'm kind of boned
[Music]
oh
there it is
holy [__] four two five two three four
eight
four two five uh two four three eight
was that it nope God damn it I got
scared four two five two three four
eight
[Music]
I don't know if that's gonna help me
oh that's awkward
oh there's balloons there
oh I gotta go ask to get the balloons
and then I go reason for problem
detective
initiating fire protocol
I don't like fire protocol
there you go okay getting away
oh [__] no don't do it
I'm just gonna
freak
[Music]
I just want to close them and then I'll
finish this hey look is that a fish good
I got a fish
gonna fish wow here's a reward
I don't know what this is but I hope
it's for the last one
here do you want this
oh boy
I don't know what this does it's a lily
pad or something
maybe it's what this douche oh I see
hey what's up time runs you know uh can
you find it wait what
my watch ran oh I know where that is I
think
oh boy oh wait wait wait wait wait back
up
I knew it I knew it I knew it I knew
that was gonna be it I knew that was
gonna be it
I knew that was gonna be it I knew it
[Music]
foreign
definitely
oh wait what the [__]
oh
we're up
bro
I don't know where dread bears I don't
care
ah he'll destroy the door
so you're saying a lot of if you see him
running to one of them I I don't really
know where I'm supposed to see him
running to one
um
I'm guessing the cameras so I actually
got close to beating that game which is
interesting all right let's try this
again I I think we're getting closer
whether or not we're getting that much
closer is indeterminate and I have no
idea where the code is
it's a new spot every time and they keep
your status over YouTube
critical sending emergency jokes I don't
know well what is it oh even if it's in
the corner of your eye
well I do not know where this code is
man that that fox is giving me more of a
heart attack than anything in this game
so
you're there
oh you moving
oh no okay well that's gone forever
what is this sound
oh boy
uh ducked uh I think it's from this side
I hear it over there I don't know man
my hello
[Applause]
maybe not
[Music]
oh
okay so the bottom right one is the one
that leads to the uh
office got it and so that must mean top
left and right are left and right and so
bottom right vent is Center I couldn't
have made that easier
I just couldn't have done anything to
make that easier
all right five four two seven seven four
two
[Music]
sending emergency jobs
come on give oh why can you not get it
[Music]
notification reason for problem detected
fire near the area initiating fire
protocol I'm getting out of here
what is that
[Music]
oh nope
you're up you're awake but where's Mr
Man
where's Mr Big Man
I'm in trouble aren't I
I'm closing the doors
I'm disclosing him I'm just gonna close
him
because screw you and screw this
taking this fish no look at this fish
give me that fish
take this fish give me that lily pad
take this go here down
to you talk to you what do you want
oh oh [__] okay
is that oh frick frick frick frick okay
hit it
this one's a toughie this one's a
toughie especially with the having to do
the whole game in the middle of it
oh check the vent map in the system
manager what are you talking about
huh
what do you mean vent map
oh God that's really convenient what a
generator status problem category
critical fascinating
that is fascinating that is very very
fascinating okay now where's the Goddamn
code
I have no idea
okay I need to learn so much more
because I do not know
developer mode required yeah okay
[Music]
I don't know where the code is
okay so he's coming down dead center I
think anyway
bottom right seem to have gone dead
center
all the other times
[Music]
unless it's more of a two of them lead
to the center
which is probably possible
foreign
goodbye
[Music]
okay I don't know why that one went away
or whatever
okay where's this code there oh there
it'd be two six five three six seven
nine two six five
three six seven and nine oh God damn it
[Music]
what is this interesting
oh that's not good well that that's I
hate that what's happening
oh God oh God what's happening is he
coming
I don't know
hi oh you went away when I'm under
interesting
notification reason for problem detected
fire near the area initiating fire
protocol
uh I guess I'm okay I don't know
see I really don't know I don't know how
I'm supposed to see when dreadbear does
something but I oh my God oh God
[Music]
oh that's what it meant by hide on the
left side because he can see me from
this side I just need to actually
physically hide from it
okay
starting to get it
starting to get it starting to get it
okay I'm starting to get it
uh open emergency doors I don't even
know what that means
[Music]
security key to verify your privileges
okay
so I need to open the emergency doors
what is that
fredbear's over there on the left
fascinating
oh
[Music]
ah got him
okay fredbear's both there okay this
should be a good chance to do this
what what is that sound
oh [__] where is he
where is he
oh God I think he's on the right but
that's okay
I'm just gonna do that
[Music]
you know
case on the left
oh [__]
go away please
[Music]
go away
oh God he's not going away okay oh frick
okay he's over there so that's good
um
probably fine
[Music]
oh oh
what was it
was it
[Music]
where's Fred Bear where's dread bear
I don't like not being able to see dread
bear
oh [__] there he goes
[Music]
okay starting to get the hang of this
huh huh
Frick okay
you're over there good stay there
[Music]
still there good
stay there
[Music]
still there
good stay there
oh I don't trust it
it's been too long
frick
Ed excuse me my watch trapped me here
what does that mean
okay what do I do what do I do
what do I do
[Music]
oh
what why do you keep doing that
stop making weird ass noises
I don't know who the torch goes to I
don't even have an option for the torch
God he's just sticking there
I think I saw that there was oh God what
what
oh God nope we're fine we're all good
watch was up here right
watch got it
get the watch to the dude but not too
much whoa whoa whoa whoa get
holy [__] what
what are you doing to me stop doing that
[Music]
oh my God
oh God yeah that's Fred Bear where is he
[Music]
he's definitely coming emergency fire
protocol failing oh wait oh that's not
good
wait wait wait time for generator
exploding five minutes
that's not good
oh wait he's back okay let's try this
again
[Music]
I don't know what I just got
what did I just get
I don't know what I got
this you need this
oh key
oh good wait
oh God he's gone where is he oh he's
moving off to the right
I think
no that's him there
fredbear
I don't know oh my god oh no
how is that supposed to oh
you get like two seconds oh man but I'm
into his progress I would have been able
to make so much more progress if I'd
actually just gone forward with
confidence instead of putzing around
like an idiot which is what I do most of
my life so I won't do that now because
I've got so much more potential inside
my soul
and I'm gonna make sure that everybody
sees it
blasted all over the Internet that's
what I do
Go baby go I'm gonna find the code
quickly
I'm not finding the code quickly
I'm not science by problem category
critical sending emergency jokes yep
okay I can't can I just start over can I
start over
okay weird
what
I'm going mad
you got you what got me
I see
I just didn't want to spend time looking
for the code I don't know what the code
is yeah I mean I guess I could have
looked for the code and then I would
have known where the code would have
been then but I didn't want to do that
we got this
there it is seven four five six eight
nine three
three
this is wonderful okay he's on the right
that's great that's great
foreign
detected fire near the area initiating
fire protocol
perfect
[Music]
look at this
I heard something
he's still there
[Music]
but they're still there you're still
there that's fine
oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] what
okay that's fine
[Music]
still there
foreign
[Music]
well that's not good emergency fire
protocol failing fire expanding
generator status critical preparing the
area for inevitable destruction time for
generator exploding five minutes wait
he's moving
that was Fred Bear oh man okay that's
why you look holy crap oh my God oh my
God
oh my God
I'm so close
okay I'm so close
whoop nope okay he's still there okay
it's good for now
almost there almost there almost there
[Music]
he's still there where's dread bear
okay
I feel like I'm getting close
oh that please help me
what I have been here for too long what
the frick
okay
I don't even remember who I was great
but I know I used to be like you I know
I was human ones oh this is not me
this is not my face
I'm not part of this game
let me
[Applause]
feel error okay that's great
um where did he go
okay he's there and I believe fredbear's
over there okay so that's good
uh whoa okay writing error log
okay that's I think that's what I need
I need uh
I need to do something with that
oh God where'd he go
you're there you're offline why oh [__]
oh [__] oh [__]
[Music]
he was moving he was definitely going to
be moving
yeah there you yeah okay so you do have
some time
because he stands on the side that he's
gonna go to I don't know why springtrap
has done absolutely dick here
convenient for me
good enough
he really has done nothing I don't know
why okay what do I need to do uh oh what
is that
oh my God what what left well I think I
don't know what the frick what was that
oh he's over there okay well that's not
what I thought it was okay what do I do
with this six two four six three
is that what I do six two four six oh
[__] oh my God oh my God nope oh my God
okay no he's definitely not that way
okay it's fine it's fine
Frick I can't even see
he's gone why is he gone I don't like
this
I've made so much progress don't do this
to me
[Music]
oh oh okay yeah yeah that's him that's
that's the one that comes to the office
I know that I know that for a fact
I know that okay I knew he was up to
something
I knew he was up to something
and that gives you a lot of time
there it is
I knew he was up to something
[Music]
okay
okay I gotta get an eye on where dread
Barry is okay he's over there but he's
not moving yet okay six two four three
six emergency fire detected in the
generator's essential components what is
going on wait what is happening
primary calculated warning to all staff
okay evacuate nearby areas and those
businesses to verify the Privileges and
open the emergency
what
but I was doing so good
ah I'm on fire
foreign
it said there was a security key oh
oh so stupid oh no it was right there ah
the Box
the freaking box this box I was so
stupid I was like where do I put in a
five digital oh man I deserve that I
deserve that okay
got this doing it doing it doing it
doing it tune it oh boy I don't know
where okay two seven three five seven
six three
273 okay
Dev mode okay put this in here move it a
little bit
move it over here
yep okay check
where things are
Bear's still on the ground here that's
good okay we should be good for a bit
[Music]
whoa what is that
so he's up now but that's fine
don't know what the weird noise is but
he's fine
oh boy that's not good come on come on
where's he going
oh he's moving okay Crouch down yes
very nice
hello
what lovely teeth you have what
beautiful big pearly well not pearly but
they're big and they're not beautiful
but they are teeth well they're not
teeth either they're made of metal
I'm not making any sense at all am I
that's okay
[Music]
can you still both there you're still
both there perfect
[Music]
I don't know if I need to go talk to him
first and then get there
expanding okay generator status
I feel like that as soon as I get to
this point in this game it goes there it
says five minutes so five minute
countdown is like faster than it has
been in the past
[Music]
we're good
totally fine
[Music]
okay let me check before before I get
into this nonsense
oh oh where are you going where are you
going oh oh oh oh oh oh where are you
going I think he might be going in one
of the vents
oh okay so that vent was Frick you
I think oh I think wait let me check the
vent map
then map six
I don't know was it came six
yeah I think that one that side I don't
know though
I'm just gonna close both of them [__]
it
man I'm lucky
good thing I did that
[Music]
wow handy
foreign so I can't escape out of this
but that's fine I've got probably three
minutes left time is a ticking usually
when you're playing Five Nights at
Freddy's oh God skip God damn it skip
the dialogue
usually uh time goes real slow because
you're trying to make it to 6 a.m but no
it's
no yeah yeah yeah whatever
oh I'm scared I'm so scared I'm so
scared come back man
you mean
come in
come on come on okay five eight two six
eight
okay
five eight two six eight got it
[Music]
five eight two
six eight
bam
what no
no oh I see oh it's different eight
six it's backwards eight six two eight
five
[Music]
86285 got it
got it key good for me put this here
do that oh God
protected in the generator's essential
components recalculating times
okay I think that means I go in here
one
oh my God open open open open open open
is it opening it's opening it's opening
oh go go go go he he ha he he hey
with my nose oh what happened to you
wait
oh
well I did it I feel great about all my
actions and everything that I've done in
my life thus far what's happening
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I'm sure this is fine
yeah I don't even need to read go let's
see what this is all about
hey wow look at you you're huge
huh a lot of beeping huh
is that important oh wait a minute wait
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute what do I do
about this wait hold on
[Music]